pilot the IMC will continue to search
for us our only chance of survival is to
rendezvous with Major Anderson sixty
klicks from our current location we will
have to improvise and adapt if we wish
to survive this is an all pass 32 we're
taking heavy casualties down here any
village afford this plane is this a long
time
I don't militia types engaging
militia now it's my turn to take a shot
just give up
first floor
go
excessive damage warning warning put it
moving it
host on using that weapon pilot
thanks to the sister secure this area
pilot this Titan weapon is advanced
design may give us a tactical advantage
I think somebody's in love a human's
concept of love for pliers aberration
attraction devotion and respect
conclusion I am fifty percent in love
pilot with the tone loadout we can lock
onto enemies and target them with
tracking rockets this the useful in
direct combat
Silas
there should be a control interface
nearby
I'm engaging hostiles
one
the pilot our path through this facility
is blocked by a flow regulation control
interface nearby
maintenance override engaged opening
flow regulation gate morning talk
a lot procedures violet the safety
airlock is sealed you in the control
room you must find another way out we
have no choice but to split up let's
split up sounds risky given our dire
circumstances this is a risk worth
taking pilot I'm tracking your location
recommend you seek and exit
tracking me it's kind of creepy BTW i
have no wish to incite fear that is
reserved for our enemies
listen up this is K what we have here my
imc and militia friends is a failure to
communicate and that's okay that's okay
it's all good that guy doesn't sound
stable agreed ScanSource is somewhere in
this facility we should not waste time
here I look okay
hooked up on something that's just a
waste go to visual